now to Kenya where a second wave of
desert locusts has descended on East
Africa estimates indicate that it will
be 20 times worse than the swarms that
made their way through the region two
months ago the UN says the locusts
present an unprecedented threat to food
security and livelihoods this is home
for the Samburu tribe they and since
recently millions of locusts the terrain
is difficult but locust trackers working
for the UN Food and Agriculture
Organization only have two helicopters
locals often go by foot
normally track the locust places that
cannot be accessible by by Road neither
by bike so if we sometimes even talk for
four kilometers in the valleys locust
swarms can engulf hectares of land and
as they eat their own body weight each
day the swarms devour practically
everything in their wake
the World Bank warns that the Horn of
Africa could lose more than 7 billion
euros worth of crops crops like Moses
Muta's tomatoes know whether God will
send us any angels the truth is that we
farmers have been totally written off
it's obvious we'll be wiped out regular
rainfall has been contributing to the
locust population explosion and The Cove
in nineteen crisis is slowing down the
fight against this infestation that were
using and what you have locked down
everything transport all this and then
you have a very slow movement of the UN
feeds 20 million people in the region
but is now warning that the number of
hungry people could double and for more
on the story we can speak to dw7 own a
co in nairobi hi Sela why are we seeing
this massive second wave well the second
wave has mainly locusts which have bred
now which which are bringing down if
European and Kenya which are not the
usual breeding grounds and
this is because especially over the past
few months there have been heavy rains
here outside the normal range season
which many experts also a tribute to
climate change and that has basically
created the perfect breeding ground for
the locusts well Kenya says it hopes
that these swarms will abate by June or
July is that really realistic well that
is the hope because June and July is
where then when they're expecting the
next big harvest but there are several
challenges to this for example they're
only Kenya and if you appear only have a
handful of Plains they have ground
sprayers in these countries and also in
Uganda but countries like Somalia for
example don't have ways of fighting the
locusts and this is a regional problem
so if the locusts are may be eliminated
in one part in one region they can still
migrate back to the regions and attack
the and attack the the farmland there
and then of course as we heard in the
report as well there is the problem of
Corona which is which has posed a big
logistical problem to to getting
equipment getting pesticides into the
country and also through the country as
they're more Road checks and so on which
which makes the the whole situation more
difficult
alright DW correspondent Sela Oneko
reporting for us in Nairobi Sela thank
you very much and for more analysis plus
key data on East Africa's locust
invasion visit our website that is DW
com